it was the same as a draw in this one  and Mama jar of advancing against pawns  imagine also his Rook will come to the  seventh and he will repeat the position  once more the draw is good enough to win  and secure a place into the finals  what a final that's going to be oh  oh it's uh two of the most informed  players the players who topped the  freedoms as well uh dude and Mama jarov  they're just so informed right now both  of them uh sometimes inconsistent those  two that's been the one criticism  leveled at them but not this tournament  they've just been fantastic they both  deserve to be there okay a check  probably King before first two one  second  so close oh yeah and my majority would  just repeat the moves again  it's over  makes it to the big final of aim chess  rapper what a performance by the 37 year  old from Azerbaijan playing well he said